blind in one eye and partially sighted
in the other
tom walker's trip into liverpool city
center can be hard enough
in recent weeks that journey has been
made even more difficult
the new obstacle e-scooters a few
saturdays ago fairly near where we're
standing at liverpool central train
station
i was walking out and the first thing i
knew was kind of like a whoosh of air
went past me and i'm like oh my goodness
what was that
and a lady a couple of meters away said
you've just nearly been run over by an
e-scooter
following a government decision to
legalize rental trials last month
signing up to use one of these vehicles
can be done in minutes after some safety
checks
campaigners are worried about their
safety though they want to put the
brakes on for hire schemes
stop the sale of private scooters and
prevent their use on the highways
they say setting off on journeys like
this should not be allowed
a message they will deliver directly to
the prime minister today in the form of
a petition
they literally take over the pavements
they're whizzing in and out of people
at great speeds you know and our members
can't see them
you know they can't hear them there's
talk about putting a sound on them but
to be honest
you're never ever going to get these
riders off the pavement
the police are also preoccupied by
e-scooters
with officers in the west midlands
launching a crackdown on privately owned
ones which are still illegal
any scooter that can be stopped safely
that is publicly owned
is subject to seizure and the riders
may be reported their e-scooter is
seized
and there's very little hope of them
getting it back
the department for transport says safety
is its top priority
with the trials meant to help them
understand the impact of these in the
public space
with the pilot set to continue until
next year the wheels on this debate
look set to keep on turning shingi
marurike
sky news